and uh last but not least we have one
more category left but before we get
into that
before we get into that we have to give
some shout outs to
you guys yeah uh and that's uh all the
people who sent us fan edits and fan art
because
the subreddit and the twitter wouldn't
be where it is without you guys and
there have been some [ __ ]
amazing fan edits and fan out that we've
received this is just like a tiny amount
that ashley found
in 10 minutes yeah honestly this is just
this is just
ashley next slide please
this is just like a really really tiny
portion
yeah of the fan edits and fan art fan
everything
place them on screen right now
[Music]
here's a highlight reel of everything
that came out yeah while we talk about
fan art and how good it is and thank you
so much and
and we we couldn't choose just one
because there was just so many and
they're all just amazing in different
ways and we really really are like
grateful we're always like whenever we
hang out or we're
just chatting we're like yo you see this
piece of sick fan art yeah yeah send it
to each other so
again we all really really we really do
appreciate it yeah and uh
i do have a surprise for you boys oh
[ __ ] one
uh do you do you want to bring it out
melin what is it
i'm scared so i you know it would it
wouldn't feel
it wouldn't what the [ __ ] is what the
[ __ ] is that am i coming out okay okay
okay ashley i get i guess you'll bring
it out ashley is better dressed
just give it to god give it to me what
the [ __ ] is this what is this
so like it wouldn't feel right having
the viewers you know having to like
narrow down
all of the fan edits and fan art that we
got okay um
but i felt like the fairest way was just
to look on reddit
right and see what was what did what did
the community
vote as like the one that was like most
memorable yeah it was like the top voted
fan uh fan arts
and so i got it framed for you boys
so this was unfortunately this was
second just behind
my laughing at corona moments on our
subreddit
but this was the highest rated fan edits
this year i remember when i spoke with
this in my meme review video i was like
look at
the god's head god dance because because
i'm the only one in this picture who is
actually me
your bodies are someone else's
man this is the pro gamer picture this
is the
i i do love this part oh my god i guess
from this point onwards every year we're
gonna
be framing the highest yeah the highest
i mean i guess i wanted to surprise you
boys because i'm just like
i feel like since we're moving studios
soon
yeah i wanted to have something for us
to remember season one
and uh this is this is going to be our
memorabilia
oh yeah that's [ __ ] awesome oh my god
that's such a nice ride we deadass did
not know that was coming
holy [ __ ] yeah i mean i guess the
champagne as well by the way
yeah and uh i think i think it's time to
get the champagne out before
uh before we talk about the best episode
of cash taste i think we got to crack
open a bottle to
oh absolutely celebrate exactly this is